oh it might be this let me let me play
you know it's funny because we live in
this culture where no fault divorce is
the law of the land and people will say
things like well look how often marriage
ends in divorce how could you ever be in
favor of social structures which
disincentivize that or would you know
dissuade people from getting divorced
but I think what people often miss is if
young folks know they're in an
environment where divorce is not an
option I firmly believe they're going to
be more careful about who they choose to
marry and I think also people can be
more careful about their decision making
in general when it comes to sexuality a
lot of people will start sleeping with
someone and as you've mentioned that
releases oxytocin and other hormones
that Bond you and there are a lot of
couples that end up together because
they're sexually engaging with one
another and they're bonding but they're
not actually really good for each other
and then at some point in the marriage
when the novelty of that person wears
off they get divorced so I think well
there it is it was Sheamus Jezebel
posted fake news a false statement of
fact